when did you find out about this good
morning Ian thanks very much for having
me on
um I was made a wheel on Monday about
the times investigation uh and took
immediate action when I have some of the
allegations we haven't yet had the full
details from the times we've asked them
for for all of the information we've got
so that we can have a proper
investigation the first thing we did was
to suspend our vato the the contractor
uh things let us down hugely
um the second thing was to launch an
independent investigation led by our
general counsel and then yesterday
morning and when we saw some of the
information from the times what we did
was we um announced that we were going
to suspend all three payment retail
installations under uh Warden until at
least the end of this winter I just want
to make sure that we can establish
exactly what's going on we've clearly
got it wrong here and we're going to fix
that we don't get everything right we
get more right and wrong but when we get
it wrong we fix it I just want to
establish the facts every single one of
our customers deserves to be treated
with respect but how did you feel when
you first saw this footage
um disappointed livid gutted um you know
this is this is not who I am it's not
the standards I sent myself it's not the
standards that um I say in the company
it's not who we are it's not how we do
business
um there's no excuse it's uh it's deeply
deeply disappointing I'm quite
distressing actually this is the
exciting bit I love this bit I mean
these are this is disgusting Chris I
mean don't you vet these people
so you're right it's there's no excuse
um it's uh
there's nothing really I can I can say
to that everybody can make their own
judgment is unacceptable
um we do we do try we don't vet every
individual member of staff and what we
do when we have a a prepayment meter
installed under warrant firstly it's
always a last resort so when a customer
gets into payment difficulty what we do
we encourage them to get in touch as we
try and get in touch with them
if the customer gets in touch with us or
they talk to us we put in our payment
plan for them so we don't have to switch
them over the prepayment meter we want
the help we want to support them we put
50 million pounds aside recently to help
those of our customers most in need we
really want to help a customer but like
any business if we have a customer
that's Fallen further and further into
debt and we cannot get them to engage
then as a last resort what we do is we
apply to the court for a warrant to
install a prepayment meter and that
sounds great I mean you're caught in
some ways you're doing a rock and a hard
place because the choices that you've
got
to leave a customer to build up that
that you know they can pay
or to try and do something which stops
that debt being built up as much as
possible there are no Pleasant outcomes
in this situation but in many Industries
you're not allowed to give customers
credit that you know they can't pay and
what we try and do in British gas in
centrica is to balance that now clearly
here we got it wrong but we've taken
immediate action we'll get to the bottom
of it and we'll get it sorted our
customers nobody deserves to be treated
like a customer don't deserve to be
treated like that
um but all I can do when I learn about
something this is is to do everything I
can as quickly as possible to fix it but
when you are getting a Court warrant to
go into a customer's house surely surely
you would want to vet the sort of
individuals that are doing that I mean
these people look like they're sort of
glorified vehicle clampers
absolutely so we have processes in place
for managing our uh our contractors and
and as far as I know the vast majority
of activity that we undertake
um in this space and in other spaces is
done with respect for customers that
allows people to have dignity clearly
people can see from the video there that
did not happen here the language is
unacceptable there is no excuse for it
so I'm not going to try and justify it
what all I can do is when I find out
that something's gone wrong is to get
the bottom of it as quickly as possible
to fix it that's why I took the
immediate steps three steps of
suspending our vato immediately of
launching an independent investigation
under our chief lawyer and then of
suspending all activity to install paper
meters under underwater
how many prepay meters have you
installed this year and how many of
those have been forced installations
so in the past year we've installed 97
000 prepayment details the vast majority
of which have been and when we say
installed sometimes it's actually just
changing over the mode so if you've got
a smart meter it can be done remotely
the vast majority have been done either
at the request of or with the agreement
of customers around 20 000 have been
installed as a result of the one process
which is in line with historic norms and
I think in line with the with the
industry
you mentioned the industry there is this
a widespread industry practice are we
going to find out that some of your
competitors have been doing this as well
so I look I can't talk for for
competitors all I can do is to talk for
what's going on uh British gas and
centrica um and to hold my hands up and
see if they've got it wrong uh clearly
in in these cases that have been
highlighted by the times I'm very
grateful to the times for um for
bringing this to my attention and say I
I've urge them to share all of the
detail they've got and must maintaining
any confidentiality so that we can look
into every instance that they that they
found I believe that the instances that
they mentioned in the report are as I
see that they um that they saw and that
was around I believe nearly 50 visits
that that reporter went on as far as we
can ask the team just now but I want to
know any instance of wrongdoom so that I
can I can fix it but also what we need
to do to do is longer term is to step
back and see this is actually an issue
which goes across not just the energy
industry but a number of Industries
which is people are struggling to pay
their bills at the moment now if you
have a mortgage or if you're renting a
property if you stop paying your bill
people don't simply sit and say they're
not going to do anything you have to
talk to your landlord you have to talk
to your mortgage company if you've got
other Finance you have to talk to the
finance provider and we're all I think
most businesses are looking to have a
solution that helps customers
in very limited circumstances where a
customer will not engage with you we
really have only got these two options
and and I don't feel very comfortable in
allowing people to build up debt that I
know that they can't repaid so what I'm
hoping that we can do is within the
energy industry I've spoken to the
regulator this morning and speaking to
the energy Minister this afternoon and
what I'm encouraging them to do is to
accelerate work to look and see what is
the root cause of the issue now there
are instances here where we've not
upheld the standards that I demanded the
team and we'll fix that the root cause
is having people unable to afford basic
necessities such as property such as
food in some cases and such as
electricity and gas we need to work
together government regulator ngos
um and and Industry in order to fix that
for those that most need our help Chris
are you 100 confident that the law
hasn't been broken in any of these
instances
in the reason I've committed sorry I've
um commenced this investigation is I
want to understand exactly what's going
on so I need to wait for the result of
the investigation but what I can say is
we'll report it wrong we'll fix it
what message have you got to the people
who've been the victims of of this sort
of short practice
I think I'm sorry it's um
it's it's not acceptable and it is not
only that it's not just the where we've
got it wrong it's wherever you see
anything is a lack of respect that's the
thing that really upset me most which is
I mean these are people these are
families you have to treat people with
respect and that's what we do we have
seven and a half million customer energy
customers in the UK and I'm confident we
do that with the vast majority of our
customers
clearly we got it wrong on some
occasions here so all I can say is I'm
really truly sorry and we'll make it
right
no last month you raised your earnings
forecast you're obviously going to enjoy
a very strong set of financial results
this year on the back of higher uh
Energy prices is there more that you
could be doing to help vulnerable
customers
look I think Ian there's always more
that and people could do what we've done
in sofard is we put a 50 million pounds
package now about 20 million pounds of
that's gone for people to pay the bill
by direct debit or by cash check
um 10 million pounds you announced this
is the reason this is so Golling is that
we've been looking at our policies and
procedures or prepayment customers just
in the last few weeks we had an internal
audit team out with arvato on other
visits in the last Fortnight so this is
an area we've really been focusing on
but we announced 10 million pounds to
help prepayment customers that are most
in need and another 15 million pounds to
help small businesses shops pubs
um restaurants Charities that are really
struggling so we're doing what we can to
try and help now that is an order of
magnitude bigger than any other energy
package that any other company has um
has announced so we're trying to do as
much as possible we've got to balance
this um this need to to run our business
and profitably because I'm a business is
not profitable has no future more than
half the UK energy retail suppliers have
gone a business in the last 18 months
because they didn't make a profit a lot
of other energy supplies are still not
making a profit without a profit they
will fail at some point
centrica has got a very balanced
portfolio and has spoken before about
how what we've tried to do is to build a
portfolio so that it's robust through a
whole number of different environments
the reason I feel very strongly about
that is the failure of energy companies
so far is costing every electricity
customer in the UK 88 pounds just now
with another 200 pounds apparently to
come from the failure of Bob I think
that's wrong the tourists in society are
paying that money we run a company so
that if something goes wrong in Centric
at our shareholders they're the cost of
that there's still too many energy
companies that may well not have the
money to back that up and therefore the
risk something happened in falls to the
energy consumer so I think we've got to
have a proper conversation about what is
an appropriate level of profitability
for energy companies to make sure that
if other companies feel the hard price
like the customers that you saw in the
Times report they are paying each 88
pounds to pay for the failure of other
energy companies I don't ever want to
have another uh another company in that
situation which is why
um I um I try to run centricus so that
it's balanced and it can sustainably
make a profit so that it can continue to
invest in customers it can continue to
make a return for shareholders and never
troubled uh energy consumers in terms of
field across